all right
ground hustle and motivate my man
always holding me down i got two
questions hustle back today what's up
how am i sounding do you hear iron
harvest music
in the background that's number two and
um
is the music too loud is it just right
let me know how that sounded
hustle my man
[Music]
all right so the music's a bit loud i
appreciate that appreciate that we're
gonna work on that right
now don't bring that down
all right so i turned down just a little
all right it's still drowning me out i
could turn myself up though
okay what about now hustle let me know
how that sounded
one two one two might check my check so
yeah we're going to get this thing going
man we're going to have
the iron devs pull up oh thank you also
appreciate it
the devs are going to pull up we're
going to do a rematch you know what i'm
saying
and uh lord addict dude monreal
you know what i'm saying our audio seems
even that's good so we're going to get
them in the room i just want to do a mic
check so you can see um undead attic
standoff you can talk to the people real
quick
just want to make sure they can hear you
testing
hello hello hello hello all right all
right petey
petey's in the bushes is that a good
start is that a good stuff
hi there we go let's get let's get let's
get this uh
voice action going
peter you know talk to the people man if
you did
but if not pity might happen you're
muted this is what it is but yeah you
know what time it is y'all we're gonna
do the rematch
so oh there peter you there
i don't know what's going on here see
his mic boom but he ain't talking just
yet
but uh yeah the rematch is going down
new content
iron harvest that operation eagle
you know what i mean and we're going
we're going to put some things to the
test man we're going to get some
some games going and codes going and
stuff like that
all right hustle says the audio is good
so we will be right back i am going to
mute
and uh yeah man expect to have some fun
in the round
little friendly competition so we see
you on a bit
lords what's going on shout out to
cologne the followers super chat thank
you he said we don't con try to compete
with far cry 6 intro
the match will last five minutes and
we've done hey hey it's gonna be
competitive hopefully
but look guys we are getting working out
a little bit of the kinks we're just
getting the
match up set up between the iron harvest
developers and
of course the iron lords of lords of
gaming.net so as soon as we get that
straight down it should be a couple more
minutes
we will start the match up operation
eagle that new content everybody's
excited about
so appreciate your patience hopefully a
few more minutes and we'll get the
match-up going
oh
[Music]
all right and we are finally live
thank you for your patience the iron
harvest developers versus the iron lords
the rematch
has returned fresh on that operation
eagle dlc we are super pumped super
excited
we got to get the competition going it's
going to be hot and heavy but we gotta
do a little
couple of introductions of course let's
start with our esteemed
guest the iron harvest devs first the
legend
sir toby pr manager at warhol studios
can you speak to people
hello please and welcome and thank you
very much for the nice introduction it's
me again
and here here to kick your ass
with the most glorious beard in the game
always good to see you man it feels good
we haven't been at a convention and do
what we normally do
but uh it's good you you are so
lucky because you could even ask cognito
i was like you know what i'm going to do
i'm i'm i'm going to look at the
cheapest tactics that these communities
use it
he was trying to employ some strategies
but we got to oh
i will i'll go google tactics that your
community has came up with
but unfortunately i didn't have time to
really sit down and look into it
okay so okay i just wanted to ask you if
that means that you're prepared
is that what you wanted to say i'm
definitely not prepared
i'm just telling you that you lucky my
pettiness had a timeline
anyway well other than that how are you
doing are you hyped for the matchup
i'm extremely hyped so as you said i i
hate this
covet situation and i hope out there
everyone is
safe but we have to hang in there it's
hopefully not not
too long uh and it will be all over and
yeah as you said i hate that we couldn't
meet
this and last year there was two two e3s
already missing
uh that would be a place yeah a bit hot
oh toby
you're michael you can turn it down a
little bit you're coming in i mean you
can turn him down
but he'll turn you shouldn't no no
bad hoes battles continue
sorry i'm i'm important that's why i'm
loud
i'm excited i'm excited that's why i'm
loud but yeah i
hate that we couldn't meet however at
least we have this online thingy going
on fingers crossed that everything
will be good soon and that everyone gets
a vaccination and stuff
you should get it and then we should
meet hopefully
next year i guess to the next e3 then
and yeah
but i'm extremely excited to to see you
hear you and play with you again
absolutely thank you for the invitation
and thanks for having us it's gonna be
fun you already know
and of course we have the iron dock
william pr manager at crotch media
responsible
for iron harvest how you doing sir hello
hello hello it's a pleasure to be here
yeah i'm doing good i'm ready to kick
some ass sonia is here and urara and i'm
gonna put all my britishness aside
get all the pronunciation problems out
there and just you know let's do this
absolutely pleasure we're gonna be
talking to you during this matchup as
well
try to get some information as well and
of course another legend
lord elliot senior designer at king art
games how you doing sir
i'm doing fantastic i'm very happy to be
here i just got off here fresh off the
rookie tournament that the
wonderful community has hosted got the
pants beaten off of me
so i hope that you're all looking
forward to
kicking my ass is
you're ready to you know reclaim your
glory
yeah perhaps this is this is simply a a
rematch right like we're going to see
how this works out
uh no we haven't won one match
and exactly course we have lords of
gaming.net and the iron lord podcast
collabo let's start with the legend the
og my man lord petey we would normally
be at a convention
together how you doing sir i am
doing well i am so excited to be here
to be able to spend some time with
everybody to be able to
get my butt kicked by my three friends
here
and uh i'm excited to be able to play
some games and see
i'm able to catch up with everybody no
doubt no doubt and of course
my man reigning from up north
and canada and all that good stuff the
legend one of the legends of rts one of
our
best players hopefully this matchup
you're talking you're talking about
addict right you're not talking about me
right try to
build up the confidence that we can okay
we need to get
bombay undead 3xbi what's going on man
oh it's good to be here it's good to be
here it feels weird being on a stream
where i have the second best beard
i'm not gonna lie it's it feels odd but
i i i'm ready i'm ready i've been
playing this a lot and uh i'm pretty
excited
nice nice that's what i wanted hear and
of course last but not least
one of the iop founding members
and my co-host with the co-most the
young wolf
himself lord of rts himself
and smoke my man gaming addict what's
going on
i'm pretty good i demand one of these
individuals on our team to uh balance
this out and
i demand toby so he can lose with us so
uh tell me i'm gonna have you to come
over here to the losing team
you're picking the weakest player here
don't it doesn't matter if you lose i'm
okay with
it
[Laughter]
no doubt another game so that we can uh
do an annihilation there's no victory
points none of that
um army size is set on high so you can
get all the mechs and all the airships
out
and yeah uh let's uh let's do this if
you'd like to ready let's do it yeah
let's do it let's get this going
and uh again as you guys start up the
match let me know
and um what we also do is just talk
about real quickly while that's going on
you know the new content obviously
operation eagle the add-on or you can
play as an add-on or standalone
experience contains the entire usonia
campaign
along with the colonia tutorial levels
so uh
just okay let's get the people warmed up
about the new content
before the matchup i know as the matchup
is loading in
sure thing so uh exactly as you said the
operation eagle is the biggest and well
the first and biggest add-on we have for
uh iron harvest and it adds the new
faction eusonia which is the alternative
american
well alternative america and they what
they bring to the table is flying units
giant airships
zeppelin like looking flying monster
monsters throwing flames from the skies
like really brutal really cool
liberalizing everyone but uh
um you're right it's it's a standalone
dlc it's a steam exclusive standalone
dlc so if you want to have it standalone
you must get it via steam
and there uh for 20 bucks you can have
as you said the
the um tutorial campaign from polanya
which is only a few
missions but the full faction or the
full campaign from eusonia
but you can still play online against
everyone you can get teamed against
everyone you can only pick
usonia and pulania unfortunately but it
doesn't restrict you from anything else
so
that's a cool thing i guess no
absolutely and i want to shout i'm
speaking to you guys offline
i want to shout out the the art team i
mean it has been phenomenal i
love the direction that you guys went
with this uh dlc so
if you want to talk about that you guys
anyone wants to come in and talk about
that i i
love what you guys are doing with that
direction
yeah absolutely our our team really
really outdid themselves with
the sheer creativity and the just the
general
looks of all the various units and the
environments that we've got going on so
i really hope that we can show off some
of the really
uh insane looking mechs that we've got
going here so
i'm sure we're gonna you're gonna get a
little text of that
very soon i want to see some diesel
birds i want to see
a lot of that man it's a lot going on so
just to recap again with you guys so
you got the add-on basically contains
your sony faction we got 20 new units
right
we doing we have a campaign single play
and co-op
three new heroes and also more flying
units for all the factions
yeah we're also essentially with this
add-on we are also giving a free update
and new additions for all players so not
just those who own the dlc which
includes
uh things like new maps uh new air units
for all factions
um so there's there's a lot to go around
for everybody yeah
nice nice we are excited and uh
right now available you guys released
this week
thursday i believe was 27 yeah it was it
was thursday
nice nice nice how how excited
about you guys that it is it is now what
you've been working on the fruits of the
labor and now is now available
to the public yeah it's sort of both
really exciting and
quite relieving as well we've been
working very hard on this for the past
several months
and just having it out there and having
people
like checking this out and being all
excited about it is it's wonderful it's
really great to see
shout out to stitch 6669 super
i'm just here to see that guy attic get
booked
all right we'll do our best addict do
you have anything to say to this
they're loading in right now get some
play-by-play
action this is looking good we've got
the uh
the nice atmosphere here very very snowy
looks like
exactly so the um the setting of this
um new operation eagle dlc
or add-on is actually antarctica so the
rusvets and the eusonias are fighting
over antarctica
and it even brings you to the hot dunes
of arabia
so very cold and very hot and those as
you can see are the new
uh yeah multiplayer maps you can see
there no doubt
no doubt yeah absolutely we go to a lot
of different places
in the add-on i should correct toby here
real quick um
for that it is the other cold place that
starts with a it is alaska
sorry
a lot of snow a lot of a lot of ice it's
uh it's easy to confuse
but um yeah so we've got a lot of
different new locations
uh to where you will be heading out as a
player where you can experience
the all-new campaign and the old new
story that we have there as well
now we here at the iron lords we're very
we're team rts
team turn-based we love this kind of
stuff so for those
who are let's say new to the genre may
be intimidated
you know what what could you help
explain to them to finally get them
ingratiated with this genre
you know as far as basic maybe
strategies and things i know you guys
are competing right now but
you know basic things to get themselves
familiarized with the genre because it's
a very fun genre once people get to
learn it
yeah definitely um so real time strategy
is quite simple if you've played a
turn-based strategy before so primarily
where
um strategic thinking
and gameplay takes a forefront
essentially usually
where you act as a commander where you
control
multiple units if you've played for
instance uh something like league of
legends it's kind of like that where
instead of controlling one
character you're controlling multiple
characters and a lot about
these kinds of games is about uh
building up a base
and arranging an economy and controlling
units to get
the upper hand on an opponent right
now one thing you guys do a phenomenal
job that i love again these these
powerful these flying units these mechs
i mean i think
in my opinion that's the strength of
iron harvest like getting a hold of
these behemoths you know
what what what's the process again for
someone new to the series do they get
to kind of generate that kind of offense
yeah so essentially to
to get to that essentially the the mechs
are definitely a very
big important aspect particularly for
iron harvest
and um that is something that
step by step so to speak within the game
is explained throughout
the very first campaign that we have
that
uh you either get through the base game
or by buying the
standalone dlc um and
just for the fellows who are playing
around along right now you can get those
mix
from the workshop which is a structure
that you can build with a special kind
of units called an engineer
um that'll have like a little build menu
for you where you can basically
set that all up which is definitely a
core part of
one of the many mechanics that usually
these kinds of games have
if you're a little bit more familiar
with the
particular like if you're kind of
wondering what kind of real-time
strategy is this is kind of closer to
age of empires or command and conquer
right um i think the closest equivalent
you could think of would probably be
things like company of heroes or dawn of
war 2 in particular absolutely
absolutely let's talk to the lords right
quick let's start with a lord of dead i
know he's he's focused right now he's in
trenches
but um you know you're a big fan of the
genre you know
obviously you covered the uh the base
game initially what are some
things maybe that stood out initially
from the dlc if you can
point out that you that you noticed or
liked or
disliked or anything you know anything
new with operation eagle that you see
well the the thing i really appreciate
is um
what like i iron harvest is
a lot different than a lot of rts games
that i've played because like
you guys talk about like age of empires
and everyone always defaults to like age
of empires when it comes to rts games
because that's
what a lot of people are familiar with
but what i like about this game is it's
like
you know yeah you you know you could
have economy building in your game but
this is just like
no how much how much firepower can you
turn out the fastest
and get rolling as fast as you can it's
very quick it's very fast
it's a lot of fun and the verticality of
the game
now is absolutely phenomenal with the
addition of airships and everything else
like i had so much fun just playing
through i'm playing through the campaign
right now the sonia campaign right now
just the ability to um go through
and you know do a bombing run with some
airships to kind of soften things up
and then uh you know be able to like
change strategies oh they've got
anti-air stuff so i need to go through
first with ground
mechs and soften things up it's just
it's a lot of flexibility
and with the game being so primarily
focused on combat that's
obviously important but it's just it's
so phenomenal to play because like you
spend a lot of your early time getting
your
ass kicked frankly by the ai i spent a
lot of time going oh i just
got wiped especially in some of those
eusonia missions if
you play on some of the harder
difficulties that uh some of those
missions get really intense really fast
i think that's what i love about the
game is it's always intense it's always
going you're always
you know i need to produce more troops i
need to it's always on the go and i
really like that versus
age of empires which is more slow burn
and
everything else this is kind of like if
i was compared it's like what doom is
for fps it's
it's fast paced it's hard hitting and
it's just it's a lot of fun to play
can i guys give you just a little tip if
don't forget to upgrade your oil pumps
and iron mines
that is something that don't worry that
happens to me as well and too many
players but this is something that is
essential
once you have them just click on them
and you can upgrade them by clicking on
the upgrade button on the bottom
bottom right you should do that don't
forget that
nice nice getting that expert strategy
yeah there's definitely a there's a very
big components to this game of
particularly like managing and
controlling your units and getting
the the best position positioning is
particularly very important with
exactly this kind of real-time strategy
where you can get your units into cover
um to help protect against oncoming fire
or
uh you can try and route around
different
enemy types to try and get particularly
for instance the mechs
have a bit weaker armor on their rear
end so that you can
uh kind of get you can kind of flank
around them to deal even more damage
so positioning is definitely a very
important aspect here
in being able to win fights essentially
no doubt shout out to stitch in the chat
he says why is attic looking so confused
right now
are you overwhelmed are you bewildered
at it
is he muted i think he's muted i can't
hear him
no no i'm just trying to get the units
out on it okay there you go
they say why you love why you look so
confused right now
no i'm not confused he's focused hard
that's the difference
he loves rts yes this is out right now
on pc you got steam gog all that good
stuff
you can get that also epic game still i
believe you guys are honest right as
well
yeah there is in fact little little pro
tip from me
to all of you uh currently there is
actually quite a steep discount
on the epic game store right now and if
you still have one of those discount
codes that they recently gave out
you can actually get the deluxe version
of this game which includes the base
game
and the dlc uh for a
quite a low price so it's an absolute
steal if you're looking to do that i can
recommend it
nice nice and of course
they got these flying nonsense going on
here
all right what's going on baby i see
that the big boys
oh wow
let's get it now we need to shoot that
thing out of the ground off that out of
the air
now don't run don't run your hammer
it's already getting spicy
i love it i love it okay
we all we all kind of learned from last
time that if you butt rush the max
things go a bit better go that way do
not go that way
oh boy oh okay yeah back it up back it
up back up back oh no
no no no we got you cornered now oh no
run run something
really nice coming in a second oh my god
that looks like something that that's
straight out of extraordinary gentlemen
man i'm scared of that thing what is
that
there's a lot of stuff happening so yeah
we've got to shoot that thing straight
out of the city
there you go boom
we have this announcement trailer yo i
got it i gotta hand it
like the special effects you guys do
when you blow these things up in the air
it's
crazy oh there it goes
shout out to whatever that is that's
commanding his favorite yeah if you love
that genre man this this iron
office is where it's at that's where
that dave jordan said uh attic is too
focused yeah he trying to win
we're trying to win understandable right
we can respect it
now so pity man let me talk to you man
so how's it feeling you know you're back
in there since last time with our iron
harvest like
as far as to do new things anything you
noticed that you liked the feel of the
game oh
i love how they added the airships it's
just it adds another depth of the game
that was that wasn't there before that
you actually have to anticipate for now
which is what i really like
man what about you like you know
obviously this is your genre man you you
come from this you play a lot of these
type of games
obviously halo wars is another one of
yours you know iron harps what's
standing out for you from the base and
now
a little bit with the uh with the dlc
operation
the biggest thing that they definitely
have going for them is the aesthetics of
the game i don't think another game
quite looks like this
the uh the fact that
when i blew when we blew up that giant
[ __ ] man it literally looked like
something giant was being blown up
mm-hmm
like his name is hindenburg getting shut
down the zeppelin if you know
and the fact that toby over here i'm
pretty sure won't leave me alone
so i'm just
randomly chilling here so standing with
my one mech here
it's marching what kind of weapon is
that alien he
this mech has in his hand it's like a
like how do you call that in english oh
it's a jackhammer or
oh yes a jackhammer a mech with a giant
jackhammer yeah
yes oh it didn't work out i do feel like
explosion
i do feel like when this game hits with
its consoles eventually
i assume it's coming to consoles that
absolutely
i i feel like it's gonna find a
demographic that
that's crazy because this this game
looks really visually impressive for an
rts
like like especially look how this
thing's moving
like yeah there's a lot of detail and
work that and time that went
into making all these mechs move and
making them basically look mechanically
plausible that they'd work like maybe
they're not you know realistic i mean
let's be honest here but being able to
actually look
get a very good close-up look of
how they work essentially if you take a
look at it like they're
feasible yeah no absolutely absolutely
and again testament to design
and uh i know toby when we we used to
you know talk in the flesh about this
we interviewed you in the past i want
you to tell the people oh god
about you know the the diesel punk and
the whole design and
and the legend you know behind it what
are the creations
sure so we call this or this universe or
this this
like alternative period we are talking
here about is the call is called
or the universe is called diesel punk
diesel punk is somewhere if you
if you know eventually you know
steampunk and cyberpunk
so steampunk is somewhere yeah
medieval times with uh steam machines or
something like 1800s and so on
then you have the diesel punk time which
is second world war first world war
uh huge diesel machines oil machines and
so on and then you have cyberpunk which
is the future stuff
so this is somewhere in between and the
story of all that
is there was this polish artist called
jacob buczelski
who at one time in early in the early
like 2014 or something like that he
became famous
because his pictures were trending on
reddit and so on he was painting this
rural
polish central european landscapes like
fields and so on and
in between those fields he plays those
giant
um mechs and stuff and this this weird
mixture between tradition
and and um yeah future elements kinda or
fantasy elements was super successful uh
there was a board game company
reaching out to them to him and
discussing a deal about making a board
game maybe you know that scythe that's
pretty
successful and then yes people people
like that so this 1920 plus universe
this artist created was taken over into
a board game
and then the um extremely uh talented
boys and girls from king art games took
over
uh and again got into discussions with
jakub rozalski to talk about a
pc version not a pv pc version of scythe
the board game because scythe is really
mostly focusing on the um yeah economy
between those
nations between those alternative
nations but
uh focusing on the war in between and
there we are so
we all originate from the idea of or
kind of the idea of
jacob buchdalski but king art games of
course put in their own spies their own
ideas their own
plans and so on and incorporation then
came up with iron harvest 1920 plus
yeah nice man it looks phenomenal and
again it's that unique
style like you said almost like a a past
and present it's
just this nice fusion right you're
getting these amazing mechs
in this time period it looks so cool
it's a very unique
visual aesthetic
like this uh makeshift look of uh
they they just built that in their own
backyards or something and then
created those future machines kind of so
i i like this
weird combination no i agree
great now lord ali i know we got to
question him from the chat with my man
back from dead he wanted to i know i
know we we're talking about the future
in council but you know the console guys
they
they want this they let this thing bad
so the question is i don't know if you
can answer it but
you know do you anticipate possibly um
mouse and keyboard support on console if
with it
when it does eventually come yeah so i
can
probably answer that so we are looking
at potentially having
an option for that uh i can't give away
exactly
when or in what way that is going to
come but yeah
we know that a lot of people have been
asking like hey where's the console
version and yeah unfortunately
with the pandemic and everything uh
things have been delayed quite a bit due
to that
but uh especially now that the uh that
operation
eagle is out the consoles are currently
uh it's currently what we're fast
tracking on right now
so that is currently the big plan for
that
um so that's the keyboard we're
definitely looking into it nice
what's up toby you ain't gonna just say
no you you kill me
don't pull out and feel bad for you come
over here and finish
in retreat no you had that you come over
here and finish this
over here mocking me oh i've done enough
i'm going i'm gonna pull back now
i thought elliott is standing there with
his lone soldier and he can
do the dirty job you just wait tell me
so you just weak it over there
you let elliott go that's what it was
i'm deciding which uh section
have you seen the bedroom carrier here
just dropping uh bombs from the sky and
producing drones
ping it so i can see it as well oh wow
oh you guys did put the ping thing in
yeah of those feedback from the
community which has been so great to
work and play and um
develop this game long they give us
ideas like hey a ping system so we can
communicate with each other better and
say hey i'm dying over here um i wanted
to i want to point out
i brought that up before the game came
out shout out to addict did he was on
the feedback with that that was amazing
that's so important to you i didn't know
what to say but
it's this features just for you there i
didn't want to see it
that's that's fine man that's fine as
long as we
we agree to disagree man that's fine
it's like when you're playing online
like and someone said oh there's
something coming like
it's hard to to really describe where
you are on the map
so it's better if you can ping where you
are on the map
no no shout out all right the defeat has
gone down the victory is coming
right gg gg ggg
real quickly red alert 3 uprising rts
gamer can you ask the developers
if of iron harvest is going to have
physical copies
for console oh
i'm not actually sure if i can say
anything
once we know everything in particular if
we know the release date and if we know
all circumstances we will definitely let
you know but
for now it's still in the in the making
so give us the time to prepare it
properly and then we will surely inform
everyone you will
you will note if you want if you want
all the hot information follow the iron
the king art games uh youtube facebook
and um
twitter if you want all that make sure
make sure guys you go and follow them on
twitter that way you
you know you get you get all the info
coming out like eight
i think what it is toby too is that i i
think we uh and undead can relate
uh the our fan base of seeing a lot of
that uh
cool collectors edition stuff and
they're
like i can't show some stuff yeah i
i have here uh i read so called
eisenhans let me just
those there you go those big ships are
very intimidating
lawyer that's our boy
that's a boy from the saxonian uh
samsonian troops so the exosuit of the
sixthones we're
we are preparing those uh steel books as
well which are pretty cool in my opinion
and uh yeah but as i said as i said give
us
give us the time to come up with
something proper and then we will for
sure
absolutely inform each and every one
absolutely we're working on it
absolutely
to you guys because i think you made a
good point to you know
there is a pandemic going on you know
and from a studio i do want to ask that
you know
it is affected studios different and i
just want to know what king art games
the fact that you guys releasing during
these conditions is super impressive
you know how challenging was that for
you guys as a team of development house
to kind of kind of maybe adapt or adjust
if
if need be to get this release out yeah
so essentially we have been working from
home
since last year march i think
last year early march and yeah it was it
was not an
easy transition because um obviously of
course you know usually if you're saying
like oh yeah people are going to be
working from home you usually have the
time to set things up and actually get
everybody organized but
here it was very much a okay no we need
to get we need to make sure that
everybody
stays safe and healthy so it was a
very rapid shift and luckily king art
has been
uh has i think handled the situation
really really well regarding this
um so yeah we've been working from home
for pretty much
throughout to make sure that our harvest
got launched in the first place
um and that essentially we
were working from home entirely during
the entire development of this dlc
wow um so yeah like it's it's taken a
bit of an adjustment time
but we luckily we haven't needed to
really slow our pace too much
right um so yeah it definitely came with
challenges but
i think we've been getting back on top
of that again and salute to you because
i'm glad you said that because i think
there's a
misconception by gamers as far as
development you know forgetting that
there is a pandemic forgetting that
these things a lot of these things would
be
done in-house physically around each
other as being toby talked about earlier
just you know not even
able to go to convention but i can't
even imagine from a collaboration
standpoint
how the adjustment how challenging that
may be now just to do things completely
different and then still put out this
great dlc
awesome content so salute to the team
and uh
everybody that uh has been working hard
to get this out to the people
oh yes yeah so sorry elliot go on yeah
no it's definitely been
a challenge for all of us really to uh
because of course when you're especially
when you're creating games like it's
absolutely huge team effort like
everyone has to
be able to communicate with each other
like clearly and quickly to get things
done on time and with the level of
quality that we want
and when you go from oh i can just go
drop in in someone's office and ask them
a question about something
and then from one day to the next
everyone's suddenly home
and we're all organizing things through
you know zoom and teams and everything
um yeah it's it's night and day and yeah
it's it's definitely something that we
we
it's definitely a struggle i think and
i'm sure i'm not the only person i'm not
the only studio that's had that we've
seen a lot of studios where
uh you know things came in was like ah
well we're gonna have to push things
back because
it's just been so incredibly hectic so
uh yeah
that's it absolutely you can absolutely
confirm that i'm sitting at warhol
studios after
all right now and we have the absolute
same problem we were uh
last year in march i believe
we started to go on home office everyone
in czech republic
well especially studios of course then
in june they opened up again because
they said okay
corona is over kind of then we had the
second wave which was terrible in czech
republic was really really terrible
from july last year we we were one of
the like worst countries in in the world
with corona numbers actually
and um since july last year or june july
last year we are in home office so it's
almost
a year for our students is at home
office the
production in the beginning was okayish
yeah it was good enough it was almost as
as if we would sit here however the
longer we are in home office the
worse the productivity gets and i
believe that every studio has the
exactly same issue people
and as hard as it sounds they get used
to it like yeah
in a bad way you're you have to motivate
yourself
getting out of those pyjamas and and do
something and
i mean in the beginning it's all fun and
cool and it's a new situation but now
you know production goes down and that's
a bad thing
and i i believe all the studios have
this problem
yeah definitely massive massive respect
to any other studio who's managed to
launch a game during the past year and a
half or so
uh it is launching or making any game
is already incredibly hard and difficult
but doing so during one of the greatest
health crisis of our time
is without a doubt like you know hats
off absolutely yeah saluti
again everyone that's going through it
and you guys humanized it because this
is this is real this is real and
as gamers like i said we're selfish we
like when is the game coming out what
but at the end of the day these are real
life issue so we appreciate
all the work you guys do i can tell you
even that me as a pr
marketing person i can i can tell you
that the studios many many studios are
actually suffering from the problem that
there's no game events anymore
so while for the people out there game
event sounds sound like something fun
well it is fun of course but for for the
smaller studios especially even for the
big ones let's face it but
especially for the small ones it's it's
the sometimes the one and only chance to
for instance show your game in the us so
e3
let's say is the one and only you can of
course go to the other
but let's say you have budget only for
one event you choose one i know
those things are not happening and let's
let's face it iron harvest for instance
had also the problem that we could not
go to any
event neither in germany nor in in the
us and that was that was bad for
everyone we had to come up with
creative solutions do everything online
and so on but
things take time before it gets it's
established and people get to get used
to it and it's just simply not the same
thing
and i really for the entire industry i
hope that we are getting to
to events again yeah at some point
absolutely and that's the hope right for
us to get back to where we
really mean through vaccination or
whatever type of protocol that need to
be followed
you know because that is definitely
something that hurts the actual
promotion of you your guys artistry and
these beautiful games that we
we definitely want to see so i
definitely want to salute you guys with
that i want to speak to the iron doc
real quick you know about how excited
now that the
the release is here you know from uh
iron harvest operation eagle how you
feeling
oh it's been great to watch the
community respond to this because well
it's actually been really hard the last
couple of months because airships is
something that's always been
asked for for this game uh right from
the beginning a long time
um and we always thought it was a great
idea but now to actually bring it to
real and not
tell anybody about it until
i'm really proud of the community how
it's grown especially since we last
uh spoke to you last year they've really
stepped up they've uh
organizing tournaments not only the
hardcore veterans but also for
introducing newer players to these
rookie tournaments which um
elliot just and god is handed to him
um and yeah there's art contests there's
all the streams that go on a big shout
out and
as a community manager it's um extremely
satisfying when a new guy comes into
your twitter discord facebook whatever
that you set up
and other community members like help
them out and like
take them under the wing and sort you
know get them up to speed with what's
going on
um which means i can then put my
attention to other places which are more
important or you know newer things
um and it's sort of like growth together
which is yeah
good night what you said because you
basically
about the you know rookie tournaments
and those trying to get themselves
into the genre telling people you know
where they need to go where they
signed up what they need to do to get a
part of this great community that you
guys have going
tournament guys uh well the iron harvest
community tournament
fellas for all kinds of tournaments they
also do 3v3 tournaments all sorts of
things
they have their own discord they're on
twitter they're
all over our own social medias so if you
just come in there and say hey
i want to learn um they will definitely
um step up and invite you to those
discord servers
um and talking strats we've got spaces
for that kind of conversation to go on
um and yeah
it's really exciting again with this um
new uh
dlc because it's a level playing field
again nobody knows what's good
it's so refreshing the matter has
shifted
analyze all that game data and see what
works and what doesn't work and then
we'll make little tweaks to the balance
which will mean these guys will have to
uh figure it out all over again
um uh i do actually an interesting
question is thought of
you hit land you've hit air
are you going to go on the sea yet
that would be cool
i like that answer but hey who knows i
mean
you know um i think elliot can back me
up on this like the thought process is
when we introduce a new faction it's
kind of based in a new play style right
yeah i mean definitely for the first dlc
for the first add-on we definitely
wanted to add like something
big and game-changing to
uh to iron harvest um i'm not sure
exactly what
the shape of future dlc is going to look
like
i think that's going to depend a lot on
how this gets received and you know
if people like it or not or yeah we will
just have to see and find out and see
whether we can uh we can do that
absolutely i'm gonna have to make a new
custom game because um unfortunately
for some reason uh a gaming adder
couldn't join it was a bit weird
that's fine we may be under a little
time constraint here sadly
there's some things going on but i do
want to speak to
undead and um addict about just in
general about operation angle you know i
saw what i did like now that you played
you know got a match in it was it was
very
very intense but
what are your feelings on that just in
general i'm going to say to the team
yeah like um i actually kind of had a
question i think this leans more into
elliot's uh wheelhouse than anything um
were there a lot of challenges bringing
in
airs airships and everything else like i
imagine that really
throws a uh wrench so to speak into
the just the balancing of everything
else because like
what was so impressive about iron
harvest is i felt like even when i was
reviewing it in
before release it was so well put
together and so balanced it felt like
you guys really didn't have to do
anything
with it to like balance it out and then
you guys did it again
with the dlc while adding in a whole
different like
field of combat to it it's just really
impressive
like what's kind of the mindset and how
you guys approach that
yeah so definitely adding the airships
into the game was
an immense challenge and something we
kind of knew like okay if we get the
opportunity we would definitely
love to do this if we can um after
the launch of the main game um so we
kind of already started looking around
and experimenting like okay
how are we going to make this work what
is this going to look like
um and this took a lot of team effort
essentially
um by talking with our art director
with the various animators um with
the creative director with design
everything essentially like we really
needed to
we knew that if we are going to get
airships in we are going to have to
uh we're gonna have to really put in
some effort to make sure that we get it
in and that it really works
well like as if it were basically part
of the core game um
so that's kind of like how we approach
this basically we knew we need to really
be careful and coordinated
on this and do this step by step to make
sure that we don't rush head-on in
and just throw something in and that it
turns out like okay actually
these particular aspects don't work or
this is just
beyond overpowered um so we're taking a
very
we've taken a very cautious approach to
that um
it's also kind of why we for this
particular for the launch of the dlc we
didn't immediately release like
a balance patch because that's kind of a
it's kind of a fruitless endeavor to do
that at that moment because everything
is getting thrown
out the window meadow-wise anyway um and
very quickly you're going to see how um
what are the most immediate problems
that come up um so yeah that is
something that we still intend to do is
that we're going to be
still doing patches for the game
regarding balance or multiplayer
um and that yeah we we are going to be
taking a look to see like how
having this out in the wild how that uh
how that changes things and where we
need to address
and adjust things absolutely awesome
lord toby i just want to see time
constraint wise how we doing i know i'm
dead we may have
some hard stuff too you guys got one
more in you or how are we doing tonight
we are we are we are free for the entire
evening so as long as
you guys want and as long as elliot and
will are free
i am free for you i gotta enter that i
respect
actually i want to know how you're doing
this i know i mean yeah i
you know uh i can i can run one more
because it probably won't last long
we mixed the teams we should we should
mention this
on playing with us and okay good
so elliot is the bad guy now well it's
your
chance just like last time it's all good
that happened last time that is kind of
fun yup that's exactly what happened
let me know if you guys are in and good
yep we're getting that second one going
on
shout out to brian heil he said um is
iron
harvest going to have a chinese faction
i can't really say at this point it's
kind of a bit too early to call
right now um we've just had like we've
just released this dlc
so right now we're really just kind of
seeing like because uh this dlc of
course
was was funded entirely by deep silver
so a lot of that is just going to depend
on like hey
how did this work out um is this
was this worthwhile and nothing that's
like do we want to do another one
um it's honestly it's it's too early to
say really so we will just have to see
yeah but generally it's a it's a never
say never thing and also
let's as elliot said let's see what the
community says let's see how
how the interest is and of course
there's many many ideas
the devs have so let's see how how much
and how far we can go there
you see how excited they are you just
put out new content they want more new
content
but uh especially eagle dlc is really
really really good so i do
heavily recommend it and if if the
people out there are not sure about the
game
as we said earlier it's it's available
as a standalone on steam so you can get
just the dlc for
1999 and i believe so half price then
the base game and i think that is
that's a fair deal if you consider what
you get for it so
um yeah shout out to kate johnson he
said he's late to the party he has no
idea what's going on with rts but he's
here to support
got to support the i love much love look
it's a job
you need to check out it's definitely
something that i mean i remember
being intimidated by these kind of
genres at first and then once you get to
learn it
you know and they do have some rookie
tournaments and places that you can
start but let me ask you this for
again another a new person to the job as
far as the campaign
like with the new with the new dlc are
we kind of like
ingratiating and getting people kind of
built up so they could understand how to
use units and
and the strategy of the game personally
um the
first couple of missions are like the
first couple of missions of the pilani
campaign so they have
helpful tooltips and they slowly ramp up
um
and from what i've seen of the streamers
playing uh they appreciate that
yes yes it's uh because yeah it's one of
those tricky genres um
many of us remember it from when we kids
but there's a whole new generation
kind of who wanna put their minds to
work and uh yeah i like iron harvest
because it kind of
tries its best to bridge that gap you
know appeal to the old school guys but
also uh
have something for the new people you
know
absolutely how do you use the ping
system
all right the ping is by holding down
the x
on your keyboard and then you can
essentially select a different kind of
ping
to indicate what you want to do there's
also
on the next next to your mini map is
also a ping button
so there's the circle thing that zoom
option is that new for you guys
that when you go in and you can actually
see where all the troops are and
everything if you didn't see
i think that's been around since the
base game so you can just check yeah
is that the um is that the tactical map
i think or
something else i it's maybe
it's just a whole over over oh yeah that
is
the tackle map then yeah it's basically
a very brief overview that you can get
the entire map so you can see what's
going on
quite useful at times all right so right
now we are playing is this the great
race is that what i'm recognizing here
awesome everybody loves this map from
what i understand a lot of people really
enjoy it
i i noticed this giant gun over here
called the destroyer canvas
well you would find that now i don't
want to give any hints as to what it
does
well the clue is in the table i mean it
looks like it destroys
that's stuff very astute assumption
i feel you've played games before
so yeah this one has a nice aesthetic to
it it's got like uh
mist from like the kind of luxury and
war as hell kind of vibe to it love the
different uh
the color palette changes and unique
environments like i said giving that
different feel shrubbery
a lot of greenery i'm liking it i'm
digging it
excellent all right some intense setting
enough
and base building going on
all right oh it looks like i'm college
looks like i'm gonna need a little help
over here this this cannon got
crazy reach oh yeah it is it is the big
stuff
all right thanks for the assist the uh
the machine guns you found
the machine gun crates because it's
quite cool that you can swap and change
in battle on the field what your
infantry units
are and that's quite a unique feature to
iron harvest i think yes
very much yeah definitely allows you to
swap your your
infantry classes on the fly so you can
react to
issues as they come up
oh i'm just a lowly engineer i can't do
anything
i'm going to kill that guy with a
machine gun and then i will have your
machine gun
oh smoke attic we're taking this this is
going down
oh he's quiet so you know he's focused
he is [ __ ]
yeah he's playing to win i have a lot of
respect for you uh podcasting guys
because you can play and talk at the
same time
my monkey brain won't do it it is it is
not an easy skill
it's definitely difficult all right
excellent
you can hit them with that destroyer
cannon there then i am going to go pick
up this rifle with my engineers
[Music]
yeah good stuff well done let's steal
their weapons
don't sound good i don't know i'll get
elliot or anything but which one did you
say you are the middle one
uh possibly i i
honestly don't remember i do not recall
where i was positioned
it is a mystery yes strategy is being
employed right now this is this is
you know i am doing some real art of war
stuff here right now advanced damn
strategy right now
but yeah like iron harvest definitely
takes a lot of cues
uh not just for like gameplay-wise from
dawn of war ii
and company of heroes uh and narrative
wise also takes quite a bit from
uh warcraft 3. so if you particularly
really like real-time strategy games
because i know like
there's a lot of people who not just
enjoy real-time strategy just for you
know oh yeah
we get to show off our tactical
superiority
uh to other players but also really are
interested in
an engaging storyline uh if you're that
kind of player then i think iron harvest
will definitely be something for you so
if you're interested in exploring
various characters in the particular
world
of the game uh then i think that this is
definitely something that would be
right up your alley absolutely
absolutely what's going on over here oh
i see it excellent thanks for the ping
oh they're utilizing the communicating
oh no yep we're we're actually we're
doing this newfangled thing which is
called talking to each other
we all know communication is op in any
game yes absolutely
very much right oh isn't it you know
talk to your friends you know where's
your question
no uh will you can i take this with uh
with this no i don't think i can take
this with this
no it's okay i got it so not to worry
if it doesn't really matter who captures
these resource points on our team
because
all these resources will be shared among
us so
oh okay
uh i got something over here i wasn't
paying attention
[Music]
oh hang on that doesn't that looks kind
of dicey i'm going to back out here
let's go boys are making an
anti-air earlier all right
oh dang there's a lot here i'm going to
back off
hang on
hang on i'm going to come over i'm going
to send some backup hang on
a lot of reassessing right now the lords
are learning
i'm also learning re-evaluating stuff
this is good this is good we like
competition
oh this is this is actually quite a lot
why is my workshop like stuck at 93
percent
uh do you have an engineer working on it
right now
yeah tom bullary oh no
all right hang on i'm coming oh no
i was too late i'm getting real pinned
down here over on the uh
north west over here don't worry i got a
i've got a friend
in front of us nice oh [ __ ] okay
[Laughter]
this is this is me not having a good
time oh the flame
nose is out i see him okay
i've decided to go for a scorch earth
policy so all your resource nodes will
be mine
i love it the dark is here there's a lot
of things happening i like it
yeah i'm gonna hit reverse on this one
oh no
no you won't play it don't forget you
can
uh harvest the um
the broke well if you don't stomp over
them and now it happens doesn't matter
but you can if you shoot down a mech you
can harvest their
yeah the remainings for some kind of
free
um yeah but the harms and iron harvests
exactly literally
almost before that is a lot of sky bikes
i
i don't know about this one i'm gonna
head on over i'm gonna try and give you
some backup over there addict hang on
undead how we feeling out here on there
y'all know you focus
i'm doing significantly better than i
was
i'll put it that way that's good that's
good that's what i want to hear
i feel that generally iron harvest is a
game that you learn pretty quickly so
you lose once or twice but then you get
the hang of it relatively quick
quick i believe so yeah you guy you guys
correct me if i'm wrong
yeah i'm getting a hold of it pretty
quick
all right you go i want you to start
shooting them there you go
all right shut that down all right we
can hang on
a little longer i can get ourselves my
second reserve out
oh shoot i forgot about the second
resist oh yeah don't forget
your don't forget your reserves people
the second reserves about let's talk to
people about that
all right so basically within uh
during multiplayer matches uh players
can deploy
a set of units which can include among
others a hero unit
and if we hang on for just a little bit
longer then i will be able to deploy
mine which is um
yeah undead don't forget to upgrade your
mind please
you have iron mine there which is still
level one
all right just oh no it's already
okay here we go on its way
okay i'm bringing prince wilhelm
oh look at that wonderful addicts got
one of those
steep motors out somebody got the air
support coming oh
all right let's see okay those guys
extended a little bit too far i wasn't
ready for that
anti-air okay wow
all right excellent
royalty has arrived on the field let's
see if i can uh
do something with that ability that you
should show off
oh i absolutely will uh i absolutely got
i
the i got the floor wiped with me with
this guy last time so i'm kind of hoping
i can use that to my advantage
i mean that's how you learn isn't it
also when you talk about the uh the new
year sonia faction i remember like each
one before
exactly what had its like distinct
personality and stuff like that like
what are the standouts for for that
faction we want to get into it
so eusonia is definitely very much about
air superiority
they have a couple of unique air
a couple of airships that are solely
unique to them instead of
uh mech so to speak so they also have an
additional ability in multiplayer that
allows them to airdrop
uh paratroopers anywhere on the map uh
it's
quite strong right now um but it's it's
something that you know it costs a bit
of resources in order to get it done so
it's got kind of a high
opportunity cost so to speak right but
you put it down in the right place at
the right time it can
absolutely change the tide of battle so
that's that's definitely where you'd
probably be coming from um a lot of
yeah and a lot of their mechs are
essentially there to also to bring
support there
and to help out there so yeah like it's
it's very very cool a lot of the
mechs kind of visually are inspired
by uh i believe it is
art deco essentially like partially art
deco kind of that particular style we
wanted to give like as
we do with all factions we give them a
unique
visual language so to speak for their
particular units kind of
give a hint as to where
like how they how they were developed or
how they were created
right all right again going on there
so i'm gonna go down and throw some
artillery onto the field
and see if anyone wants to uh
follow me up on this
let me see here oh shoot
oh [ __ ]
how do i select all units again uh you
can
do that with i think it is f4
or f5
it's one of the function keys i believe
nice thanks
also i wanted to ask about you know i
know we said this new content
so you're gonna let obviously your sony
sony's here you know they've got their
strengths
but i know you said you you know before
you even deal with meta and balance
patches you're gonna let this kind this
meta kind of settle but
what i wanted to ask you is prior before
operation eagle
you know what did you guys learn as far
as the meta and the sandbox as far as
adjusting buffing nerfing certain
factions or certain abilities
so essentially so it's not 100 my
purview but i can probably
talk a little bit about it uh but we
definitely noticed that for
several units there uh you have to be
very careful with how you handle them
where even the slightest value
adjustment can
be the difference between something
being maybe a little
under tuned to something being very
overtuned
yeah yeah perhaps overpower even if one
would
want to say that so um definitely one
thing and that's kind of
been our our philosophy regarding
balancing
is that we take our time for that we do
not like it's
obviously it's fantastic that we get
feedback from
all our players uh who can actively give
feedback on our official discord
server um so we definitely all take that
into account
um and we make sure that we collect
enough data so we get like the
combination of both
actual objective data to say like okay
what are people using how are people
using them um
as well as the experiential side of it
so like what do people
feel is overpowered um
and that is something like what cup that
combined we use then to make informed
decisions
on what do we need to change where do we
need to
and how do we change it uh generally
particularly for
for design there's a lot of levers uh
that you can change with various units
uh so yeah we definitely we definitely
take our time to make sure that the
changes we are making are the right ones
it's a
very much measure twice cut once okay
yeah got it
definitely good shout out to che dupree
in the chat he says art team
here so i'm assuming this is king art
games art team he says art deco
and streamline were the design
principles behind
sonia smiley face there you have it
yeah thank you for joining us i mean you
got you guys are the americans the real
americans so tell me how do you feel
about the eusonias
let's talk let's talk to the addict and
uh so pete that's a big do how you
feeling they are
like feels very strong
like that air support as well what about
you on dead and attic like what are you
guys feeling about your sonia from uh
it was fine this big ship showed back up
it's it's a uh it's an interesting
concept i like the animations on these
machines
i can't get this thing to even shoot i
don't even know how to shoot with them
let me have a look oh boy
yeah i see who's shown up here oh that's
uh
he said greets to elliot it's robert he
said
oh hey robert yeah robert is i think he
was
one of the main concept and uh 3d
modelers for
the usodium mechs you see here so a lot
of the cool looking
airships uh actually the really big one
that you're looking at here that is his
handiwork
oh salute luther robert in the team yet
i've been i've been singing the praises
man i
really like the art style and i even
like the
promotional art for your song it's
really
really very very patriotic very i'm very
strong
i'm loving the aesthetic for sure
yeah we definitely generally take a kind
of a playful approach to
how factions are grown essentially
in iron harvest and we definitely
thought well for the united states we
all kind of know like some of the key
aspects that a lot of people recognize
for
uh americans so let's let's take that
let's dial that up a little bit to 11.
yes and let's let's do that in kind of
like a playful
way that uh i think can resonate with a
lot of people but also you know
it's like give it a little bit of a bit
of satire as well
you gotta have some fun with it man like
i said just for those who
who on the stream i'll i'll blow it up
because i actually
love it and this is what i'm talking
about like just even the promotional
artwork right there for those live
doesn't that look fantastic man this is
what is this fire nonsense going on
right now
like barbecue time
what is happening that's all good we got
our own
it's 5 000 degrees of freedom
all right it's less than half health so
we can still do this
let's go home alive
let's go jessie abbott he said he loved
the designs robert he said they remind
him of his toy steam engines as a kid
yeah this particular looks really like
uh what do you call this retro futurist
kind of trains i believe was actually
definitely part
of that inspiration i'm sure that robert
can attest to
all right they're just destroying me
wow the fire thing is a feature is a
is a special a special attack you have
to select it and if you click on the yes
there you go
oh there you go wow wow
oh there he goes
oh it's epic right now it's going down
oh looks like i'm in trouble i'm in
danger
i hit him once boom oh
welcome back welcome back to playing
iron harvest with elliot
now as you can see here this is uh my
usual strategy here and long time
followers of the channel will probably
know this is pretty bad right now
oh man that was all right that showdown
was epic
i like the damage stays on the field yes
yeah there's a piece of
something rolling around i guess it's
yeah whatever there's a piece of turbine
or something rolling around on my screen
here oh there it is
nice oh wow
the robert he said lots of the design
inspiration the reddit community got
already quite right lots of demo
marked based on old steel streamlined
design trains
works of raymond lowell and tractors
very cool very cool very cool
all right i think this is my swan song
here right now
elliott's sneaky doing sneaky stuff
yeah i've been desperately trying to
revive my uh my hero here but
looks like you have your bases covered
so i think that's it on my end
all right it's now up to you 3p1 3v1
let's do it
carry exactly
it's all about belief
revere airship inbound so
who can get the flames on oh we've got
two of them here for the flames yeah
oh dear all right you ready to do the
flames three
no no i don't have flames yet i mean you
can do it
do it just because i it will take too
long
this is really a scorched earth policy
now
wow wow
that is toby
i can't i can throw smoke renee
yeah i'll help now
everybody but dude this was so really
weird
see one one more match and uh yeah it
was really played everybody
well play match love it
iron harvest operation
eagle the devs have done their thing
once
again but
very competitive more competitive this
time
and that's a lot of fun man so let's
talk to the people real quick
let's talk with the lords first you know
it says start with
lord attic man how we how we feeling
about the new content and just a couple
of matches that you got in
like i like the uh the ships i think the
animations for them is nice
i think they they put a unique aspect to
it i
i didn't know you could shoot them with
the cannons at first uh
those cannons do a lot of damage but by
the time i figured it out
toby done wrecked my stuff so you know
it is ordered i was able to kill like
two of his ships
with just one cannon i almost had that
big one gone but
he kept moving and the cannon is not
fast
so you mean the anti-tank gun right the
small one
they look they look weak but they are
super powerful so
having them and position them correctly
and then you can do a lot of havoc
it's it's definitely a nice aspect that
the ships that the
air forces bring in the game
lord undead two matches in operation
eagle how we feeling man
and there might be music oh there we go
thank you uh yeah absolutely fantastic
and uh it makes me hate the fact that i
gotta go out and do stuff
and not sit here and play all these
yeah and play more of the usonia
campaign because that's that's really
brilliant and who uh
just before i dip out here i just want
to tip my hat
to uh whoever the cheeky person is that
does the script writing for the campaign
because the eusonia campaign
had me uh laughing a lot uh so far with
some of the little uh
jabs so to speak it's it's really good
oh wonderful i'll be sure to pass that
on to the writers
pd two matches new content new dlc how
we feeling about the new content man
i'm i'm really loving this this is so
much fun you know
it really brings me back and being able
to play this and
the upgraded version of um i shouldn't
say upgraded the changes that they've
produced with the up with the expansion
or patch whatever you wish to call it
it's beautiful i love how the airships
give this whole new depth to everything
i really like it absolute pleasure of
course
let's talk to him man you guys got it
out the content is available
how you feeling as a studio as this
thing is finally
out to the public yeah it's a big relief
uh and it's
even more a big relief to see that
actually people like it
you know um and yeah again it's
the excitement for me is to see how the
community will take it and run with it
as always because it takes us time to
produce more content
so it's kind of on them to um yeah
surprise us with the new ways that they
play and we'll adapt to that
as always you should totally have a an
armored unit that's uh that's a mech
that just shoots harpoon air units and
they can't leave until they're destroyed
like the moby dick with the harpoon
absolutely ahab sorry we'll call it ahab
there we go there we go
again that was a community manager at
cuff media salute and
of course always a pleasure giving us
the the
background the the details the nuances
senior designer at king art games my man
lord elliott man
it's out now operation eagle can you
breathe easy
are you happy now that the fans are
gonna get to enjoy this great creation
you guys put out
yeah i think i speak for both myself and
everybody that we're
incredibly thrilled and relieved to have
this thing out and for everybody to play
it
uh but obviously no rest for the wicked
uh we still have of course the console
versions which
are gonna be probably up next uh
hopefully we'll have more information
about that
in due ports and yeah so then heads down
eyes uh eyes forward and uh we will see
what comes after this
our console brothers are very excited
they're salivating they cannot wait
to play this thing they're super excited
and of course the
legendary greatest building game my man
who i miss seeing in person lord
toby sir toby pr manager warhol studios
my friend
how you doing this thing is out it looks
great
plays great how are you feeling sir i'm
feeling really good
especially if you consider so the story
with me is a little bit tricky you know
i'm the peer manager at warhol studios
but
warhorse is part of koch media which is
a big publisher and i'm helping out cook
media with other projects and iron
harvest was my first project
that was not connected to wahoo studios
so for me of course
i i treated it as mine as my baby
i adopted it so to speak and i i
love it i i'm with the team now with
king art for almost
it's it's almost two two years already
working on iron harvest
and it's uh it's cool it's really cool
that uh
and like personal relief that everything
went smooth the game is out people like
it
people buy it there's new content coming
there's the community that is really
engaged
interest with there's still interest by
media by you guys
by general content creator so that's
that's a very good thing
and since we're here already in this
very nice round i would also like to
tell you that coch media since we are
now
talking about friends right cochmedia is
planning something very big
very very big in the mid of mid of june
and you guys should definitely
it should definitely be on the lookout
maybe there is a lot of
there's probably a lot of stuff for you
to talk about on the iron lord podcast
oh
i can't wait mid mid june
huge huge things coming and you know
it's uh
june starts next week so yes yes and we
will come across e3 week so we will
definitely
because it will be next month is going
to be so packed well
toby is eating things and i like when
toby hints things
yeah yeah yeah yeah you should that that
would be huge guys
mark mark my words oh oh i would say i'm
going to be
tuning in maybe
maybe you then invite me to the podcast
you will be back
you know that the schedule's a little
bit crazy because you know what happened
can't get rid of me of course now your
friends your friend to the realm
always show tremendous love and uh last
question
all right chad i'll give you this last
choice they can't because these are the
console guys
they can't get enough the question is
they want to know
if shout out to uh dark light if when it
does come to console
is it coming to game pass
i know you can't answer but i had to put
it out
well i can't i can tell you that i love
game pass and i would love to have
uh games as many as possible there
because i think it's a great thing
however
it's too early to know there's a lot of
deals that has to be made and so on
we cannot promise anything that
eventually won't happen or the other way
around so
again we well king art games and [ __ ]
media but king and games a little bit
more is
very communicate communicative so if if
there's news you will definitely
know about them and the easiest way
would be twitter i guess
exactly follow him at king our gamescope
media all that good stuff again
exactly exactly harvest operation eagle
right now
pc steam epic game store gog
just dropped 20 uh may 27th please
check it out enjoy it great game great
community and of course stay tuned to
their account
they may have some announcements coming
on and uh toby will
may have to come back and uh discuss
that with us
we are signing out everybody enjoy your
saturday this was a lot of fun again
iron lord salute king r games thank you
so much this was a lot of fun as always
sweet pleasure have a good one peace
thank you everybody
see ya
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh